en plena resaca electoral paraguaya es
el balance de sus elecciones donde hay
dos claros ganadores por un lado el
partido Colorado no solo ha conseguido
de nuevo la presidencia sino que ha
arrasado literalmente las dos cámaras 23
de los 45 senadores y 48 de los 80
diputados le dan una mayoría muy holgada
para poder gobernar sin tener que hacer
ningún tipo de Alianza además el 43% de
los electores paraguayos ha demostrado
no tenerle miedo a Horacio cartes el
presidente del partido Colorado
considerado corrupto por el gobierno de
los Estados Unidos y quién fue incluso
investigado por la justicia brasileña
por ser responsable supuestamente de una
gigantesca red de lavado de dinero
cartes tendrá un papel muy grande en el
nuevo gobierno incluso porque
Santiago Peña es su delfín ilía lavó
nada más conocer los resultados
electorales además se espera que las
próximas semanas el gobierno de los
Estados Unidos podría emitir una orden
de extradición Descartes y es muy
probable que Peña se resista el otro
gran ganador de estas elecciones es el
antisistema paraguayo cubas que ha
conseguido un espectacular 22% arañando
mucho de esos votos a la coalición de
izquierda además ha conseguido cinco
senadores la más votada es su esposa y
el segundo más votado es un artista
plástico que está haciendo juzgado por
una supuesta agresión sexual a una niña
de 13 años finalmente el gran Derrotado
es la coalición de la izquierda que ha
perdido muchísimos votos concretamente
en el senado el frente guazú el
principal partido de esta coalición solo
ha conseguido colocar a una senadora y a
una única diputada de izquierda ahora
mismo en el parlamento